contrairement aux autres grandes
capitales européennes les rues de
stockholm n'ont jamais étaient désertes
ces deux derniers mois
allez à la pandémie qui touche la
majorité des pays du monde y compris le
leur les suédois semble presque épargnée
par cette situation inédite
de son côté le gouvernement ne cesse de
rappeler dans ses discours
sa ligne directrice cette lutte contre
le coc u19 est un marathon et les
mesures prises ont donc été choisis
parce que nous croyons fermement
qu'elles sont viables à long terme
la vie ne se déroule pas normalement en
suède et pourtant pas de confinement les
bars les restaurants les commerces sont
restés ouverts tout comme les écoles
primaires et les collèges
face à la crise sanitaire les autorités
ont misé sur le bon sens et la
solidarité nationale les règles de
distanciation sociales sont conseillés
pas de masque obligatoire le travail à
domicile est encouragé les personnes
âgées de plus de 70 ans sont incités à
s'isoler
seuls les rassemblements de plus de 50
personnes et les visites en maison de
retraite sont interdits je pense que la
stratégie suédoise s'est avéré durable
je veux dire que nous obtenions des
chiffres maintenant que les gens
adhèrent de plus en plus à nos conseils
il est apparemment assez facile de
commencer un confinement
mais l'arrêté est beaucoup plus
difficile de convaincre la population
qu'un jour vous êtes censé faire ceci et
le lendemain vous êtes censé faire autre
chose et je pense que cela revient à la
question de la durabilité la durabilité
est très importante lorsque vous
travaillez avec la santé publique et les
maladies transmissibles anticiper une
deuxième vague
la stratégie de la suède repose sur
l'idée que le virus ne va pas
disparaître de sitôt et qu'il doit
circuler lentement en 100 de la société
pour ne pas engorger les services
hospitaliers avec 1100 lits disponibles
la capacité d'accueil a été doublé dans
les unités de réel
mation le système de santé suédois se
prépare à une situation qui pourrait
durer plusieurs mois
nous prévoyons de travailler ainsi
pendant tout l'été et nous devrons
ensuite continuer à analyser l'évolution
de la pandémie et nous le faisons chaque
jour chaque semaine pour voir où nous
allons si le nombre de malades augmente
si nous avons plus de patients et nous
continuerons à le faire aussi longtemps
que nécessaire probablement toute
l'année une sérénité symbolisée par la
cote de popularité en hausse du
gouvernement selon l'institut de sondage
nos bus 63 % des suédois sont satisfaits
de l'actuelle gestion de la crise
sanitaire avec un bond de 20% en un mois
fin avril le responsable des programmes
d'urgence de l'om est-ce déclaré que la
suède pourrait servir de futurs modèles
en matière de lutte contre le coc vie 19
[Musique]